we did about eight or nine months of
research where we really looked at the
animal world to try to figure out what
the plot of the movie would be what the
characters would be experiencing and in
that research we discovered this
interesting divide between predators and
prey that we came upon where you have
ninety percent of the animals in the
world are prey animals and ten percent
are predators so you have this automatic
majority-minority to groups that don't
get along and that really fed sort of
the the stoke the coals of what drove
the movie from then on not only in the
plot but also what the main characters
are in conflict about so it really did
evolve naturally and because it's a is a
talking animal movie in a contemporary
world I think that's something that we
bring you know contemporary references
into it very easily and assuming list of
like an expected trope of this format I
think I think that we we decided to to
challenge the genre of talking animal
stories films not so much challenge what
a what a Disney movie is because I think
we're of the the mind that the
filmmakers that are making if it's made
at Disney it's a Disney film and and
were were conscious of the legacy you
know but also that the the film's need
to speak to today's audience so we're
always trying to keep one foot and in
timeless and in one foot and timely so
so though we were kind of pushing the
boundaries of this type of genre we we
wanted to be respectful of the legacy
also how long has this been in
development it's about five years right
now it's about five years ago it was
what was the kernel Oh Michael was still
in college yeah he's very young it's
very to the third time
I was gonna do it this time I was gonna
graduate Michaels determination to
graduate from school so five years ago
right after tangled Nathan grano and I
who had directed tango pitched we had
six ideas to John Lassiter in the way
you guys know John said John the way he
likes you to come in with these ideas is
not just to bring one idea but bring
many and we I think we came in with six
different ideas and they were all
different things like one was a version
of Three Musketeers one was a sort of a
kind of a crazy Roger Corman b-movie
idea
one was about animals in space one thing
they did have in common was that they
all had anthropomorphic animals and
Johnson well I don't know about these
ideas but this this anthropomorphic
animal thing is really interesting
because Disney hasn't done one of those
in a long time we did Robin Hood way
back when and John grew up on Wind in
the Willows which was Ichabod and mr.
toad that compilation movie that Disney
did back in the 40s and 50s and so we
we'd got very excited about that because
now we had never done one in CG
especially and that's something that
even our animators they you know they do
human animation a lot and they're
brilliant at it but even to give them
something new to do and this world where
you have so many different animal
species everybody's limbs or different
lengths and the and the acting is got to
be different depending on the species
got everybody very excited what we had
pitched back then was actually a spy
movie it was a spy movie that I was very
excited about spies at the time and I
thought this would be a great thing we
had this animal world but as we pitched
this movie over and over again the
feedback that we got back from the story
trust was that the spy movie thing
wasn't the most interesting part of the
world that we were developing it was
really this first act where you had an
all animal city and everyone was saying
well that's that's unique what if you
guys expanded that and made that the
entire film and that's where things
really kind of dug in and that's what
that's what we dove into that research
the way I work generally as I will watch
something I will think about it and I
will write a piece of music that
reflects the way I felt when I saw it
and what I kept coming back to was this
very sort of sort of sad and
disillusioned feeling in the music it
was just the sadness and disillusionment
and I kept thinking well this is soot
Opie has also got this funny stuff and I
fell
you know but I just kept doing this this
this is what I kept coming back to and
and I said I said well I'm just gonna
show it to them and see what they think
I said here's what I felt about your
movie it's sad and I felt
disillusionment and but it was to me the
truth of the film you know - I kept
thinking about the character of hops and
this character was so optimistic and so
idealistic about everything and
everything is gonna work the way I want
it to because that's just the way the
work it the world is but I know that in
all of our lives as you get older as you
grow up you and this is a warning to you
kids out here you will be disillusioned
there are things you learn that really
well hold that's the way it really works
or that's the way it really is and these
are the things as you're growing up you
just don't even connect to it don't even
realize and it's for me the film was
about that moment in our lives and we
realize I'm not looking at this in the
right way I've been really kind of
looking at life in a very sort of
superficial you know mostly about me and
it's not until you reflect and look at
it look at it and through the eyes of
somebody else that you understand sort
of what life is and that's where I came
from with the music so I mean I played
it for you for the first time for you
guys who came over to the house and I
said okay and I remember playing it for
them and thinking I don't know how
they're gonna think about this but that
you can you can talk about that well
that's that's that's sweet that he could
compose an 8 min a suite for us and it
begins with that very poignant piano
theme there's a single note that rings
out over and over and over you know I
don't think we knew what to expect at
all I think I mean we just said well I
knew that you would get to the heart of
it you know I I he is like a detective
you know he's the the meetings that we
would have the conversations that we
would have and just kind of hanging
around with you and and even being at
your house and kind of you know how we
would kind of talk about the things in
your house he's picking up little thing
it's not just about the movie it's like
he's getting into our heads also you
know as as he's as he's building this
thing so I had no debt and I could kind
of feel like wow he's really he
really doing his homework here so I had
no doubt when he was gonna play it that
it was not gonna be on the surface yeah
funny cuz I thought it would be the
opposite I thought you were gonna do to
me what I did you the first well the
other thing too is that one of the
reasons we asked Michael to do the movie
in the first place because we knew it
would be a very diverse score because
you have multiple worlds in the city you
have different environments that kind of
call for you know slate like kind of
Russian Italian vibe in the Thunder town
district you have the rain forest
district which has sort of a kind of a
South American vibe and we knew how
versatile he was and so we were hoping
he would say yes and there was also
something he brought to that we did not
expect because Michael is a huge fan of
1970s cop shows and so we were giggling
over in the corner there as the credits
were playing because there's a theme
hero called Hill Street zoos we just
sort of that okay this is funny right
that is kind of a take on these old kind
of Quinn Martin you know the cop shows
for back then and it's it feels like
what's great about Michael is when you
meet him for the first time and sure a
lot of you guys know him but you feel
like you've known him all your life and
I think we rich myself and Clark really
felt like we dived with this guy because
like you love planet of the apes growing
up we look planted they have Speed Racer
all these great shows and Star Trek and
Star Wars and so there's something about
that bonding where I think we just felt
like we understood each other and then
the fact that he can dive into this vast
warehouse that he's got in his head
musically and it can pull out little
pieces of whatever is appropriate for
the film and bring that to the it's I
don't know that anyone else could have
done the score is pretty pretty
impressive to us and well done and and
hat we do a lot of these movies all of
them I think come from us sitting in a
room talking very personally about
ourselves and our personal experiences I
think rich and I had both experiences
with bullies growing up and that that
found its way into the film late but all
of the story sessions are alike that we
get in the room and we go okay well if
something's working why is it working if
it's not working why is it not touching
you emotionally and that just naturally
brings out people talking about their
own issues and because we do have a very
diverse group of very very smart people
we we
work with and we rely on our crew to
tell us about their own personal
experiences that will inform and educate
what we're trying to say with the film
so it's not just us by yet by any means
it's it's really a group of people who
are giving us personal experiences and
information that's going to tell us how
to tell the story and then as far as the
as far as the humor goes as far as like
kind of balancing the mesh because we
knew it had it's something about
something very serious but the humor
kind of tends to allow us to leaven the
message early in film because we never
wanted to make a message e film we
didn't start out to go we're gonna make
a message e film and prove a political
point at all it was really about the
emotional journey of the characters and
about what they're going through and
telling a solid story that makes you
feel something and that all just is
oddly timely I'd like you said it's
strange that it came out right now and
this year and that all this stuff in the
world is happening right when this is
coming out but it really was just all
based on us trying to tell a good story
and for myself personally of being able
to kind of balance it in my head I'll
work out like a little formula in my
head for anything that I work on and to
me this was Richard scary's busy-busy
world meets LA Confidential you know
that it was it was that type of thing
where I could kind of that gives me kind
of a chart that I can now navigate from
as a director and the really really
juicy concept of the initial idea to me
was not just doing a talking animal
story where they live in a world where
they all get along but the idea of well
how how did they get to that point you
know we know animals we how can a lion
in a lamb you know work side by side and
the lion not kill the lamb and eater you
know so the idea of like what we're
going to explain how that happened you
know we're going to we're gonna dive
into to that to that moment that that
made that achievable to them and then
deconstruct it and then throw a bomb
you know into busy busy world and and
and make it feel like our world you know
and make it feel contemporary so it's
kind of taking things that we
collectively know from our childhood or
stories that we've told our children and
and try to find more depth to it